when you and I were together we talked
about bright Minds right that if you
want to keep your brain healthy or
rescue it if it's headed for trouble we
have to prevent or trade the 11 major
risk factors
that steal
your mind but ultimately I worked with
BJ Fogg at Stanford for six months on
creating tiny habits for brain health
okay the mother habit the most important
habit is this three second question you
just ask yourself is this good for your
brain or God for it and if you know the
less and quite frankly most second
graders know the list I went to my
daughter's second grade class and I
wrote 20 things on the board and I'm go
separate them for me good for your brain
or bad for your brain and they got 19
out of 20 things right okay the only
thing that missed was orange juice which
is bad for your brain because it's too
much sugar but other than that you know
people sort of have a sense alcohol is
really not great for your brain
marijuana is not really great for your
brain hitting soccer balls with your
heads probably bad for your brain if you
know your brain is soft and your skull
is hard
um
but bright Minds for me it helps bring
it home in a more scientific way
and so for example B is for blood flow
low blood flows the number one brain
Imaging predictor of Alzheimer's
and you had beautiful blood flow which
was a huge shock uh get in your history
right I agree I even Yesterday Mindy
adjusted my neck and she was like oh
you're Atlas and she like adjusted me
and um and uh you know even from that
perspective it seems like you know that
would pinch things off too you know what
are the things that lower blood flow
um not exercising right excessive
caffeine nicotine
[Music]
um
erectile dysfunction and I don't know if
you know but the statistics are scary
of 40 year olds have erectile
dysfunction 40 of 40 year olds
70 of 70 year olds and I'm like no I'm
not okay with this but it comes from our
poor diets our lack of exercise our
incidence of diabetes and
um if you want to increase blood flow so
each of these risk factors go well how
do you prevent it right
um exercise probably the most important
thing you can do yeah Beats cayenne
pepper the supplement genko
um all of these things can increase
blood flow and so I want people to have
blood flow Envy uh because just so
important so whatever is good for your
heart is good for your brain and
whatever's bad for your heart is bad for
your brain and it turns out sexual
function and it seems like a basic
question but what is the what is the
brain's function and I'm only I'm asking
that because well one it's just I'm just
kind of curious what your answer is but
also there's just so much curiosity
around like how the Body Works what is
our reality Consciousness and how
everything plays in so what do we know
because there's a lot that we don't know
about the brain is that accurate too you
know people say that a lot but there's a
whole bunch we do know
and if you heard certain parts of your
brain you tend to have certain problems
so if you hurt the front part of your
brain
well it's the executive part of the
brain
it's involved in focus and forethought
judgment impulse control
organization planning empathy learning
from the mistakes you make so what I
like to teach people to do is how to
have better frontal lobes and in that
way they have a better life
because they know what they want
and they see the future on how to get it
and then they act in ways that are
consistent
with their goals so for all of my
patients I do an exercise I love called
The one-page Miracle on one piece of
paper write it down what do you want
relationships work money physical
emotional spiritual health what do you
want and then another tiny habit after
you do that is before you go to do
anything or say anything you just go
well does it fit does my behavior set
the goals I have for my life and so many
people have never like if if you have a
good business
you have a plan on what are you going to
do this quarter and this year in three
to five years from now
most of my patients I've seen over the
years they have no plan and so they end
up going from crisis to crisis but
that's what your frontal lobes do
is they plan they organize and they keep
you on track and when they're hurt
from a head injury or heavy metal
exposure or
um a near drowning episode sure
their level of impulsivity is high
and they don't get their goals so it's
sort of like you drive it
without good breaks
and so if you imagine yourself in a race
car at the top of a mountain
and you don't have good brakes you're
not getting to the bottom and you may
die in the process not in one piece
that's what happens when people have low
frontal lobe function now if you have
high frontal lobe function it's like the
brakes always on so those are people who
have OCD so so the purpose of the brain
is to be aware and control your life to
think it's to feel it's to act it's to
interact when it's not healthy and I've
seen a whole bunch of unhealthy brains I
have over 100 murderers that we've
scanned their brains are not healthy
yeah well I was very curious about that
that was um definitely I wanted to get
to that with this Dahmer documentary on
Netflix being so popular I think it even
I think I even saw it said that it was
one of the most popular on Netflix uh
Netflix history what is it that you've
seen with
um evil people
sociopath Psychopaths serial killers I
mean I guess I can't say that you I
don't know if you've had serial killers
in there before but it's not uncommon if
you're in the clinic that somebody shows
up in an orange jumpsuit in handcuffs
and shackles and
um I had one guy with a cobra tattoo on
his skull he was a pretty wicked at
least his behavior was wicked and you
know what I learned
is the people that do bad things
often not always but often have Bad
Brains and so I've testified in death
penalty cases and
um you might remember Kip King Cole who
in 1998 murdered his mother and father
so he brought weapons to school he got
arrested his mom and dad picked him up
from jail at six o'clock at night and
sometime between six o'clock at night
and eight o'clock the next morning he
murdered his mom and dad and then he
went to his high school in Springfield
Oregon and shot 25 people
um and based on my work they scanned him
in Oregon Health Sciences University and
they sent me the scans 15 years old it's
got the most damaged 15 year old brain
I'd ever seen and you know he murdered
his mother so I don't exactly know why
but it could have been a lack of oxygen
at Birth it could have been an infection
it
um
there was something poisoning that Poor
Boy's brain now I always think of people
in four big circles we have a biology so
the physical functioning of our brain
and body we have a psychology which is
how we think and our development we have
a Social Circle
um what's going on in our life right how
are we doing in school what are
relationships like do we have money and
a spiritual Circle which is so why the
heck do you care you know why do you
think you're on the planet what is your
deepest sense of meaning and purpose and
I see you as a very purposeful person
when you think of serial killers
they have problems in all four of those
circles
because quite frankly you can have a bad
brain and never do anything bad
and so kept what I got to know about him
is there a trouble in all four of those
circles his purpose in life was to be a
mass murderer
um he had very bad thinking and was
isolated and disconnected then yeah I
scanned Byron Katie she talked about it
publicly she's a spiritual teacher and
she had a terrible looking brand and
before she had her Awakening she woke up
on the floor of a halfway house in 1986
and realized that when she believed her
thoughts she suffered but when she
didn't believe her thought she didn't
suffer I mean it's so cool so powerful
she had a bad brain but a wonderful
spirit
[Music]